by itself does Ukraine have a chance of
resisting Russian military power a
conventional war Russia would win easily
the military balance of power is
overwhelmingly in Russia's fate its
defense budget 28 times larger than
Ukraine's Russia has approximately eight
hundred fifty thousand active duty
military personnel and two million
reservists Ukraine has 140,000 active
personnel and 1 million reservist some
of whom are now being mobilized in the
air Russia has comprehensive superiority
with 1,400 military aircraft including
some of the most advanced fighter jets
in the world Ukraine has about 200
military aircraft that's a seven to one
advantage for Russia at sea Russia is
also superior the Russian Navy is a
force to be reckoned with it's 64
military submarines many of them
nuclear-powered Ukraine is struggling to
fix one submarine but the conversation
ends with this one fact Russia has
thousands of nuclear weapons and
hundreds of delivery vehicles Ukraine
the zero but all this military power may
still not be enough for Russia to take
control of the Crimean Peninsula it will
need to win the hearts and minds of
people
and for that Russia will need to deploy
the more delicate tools of good
governance which have so far eluded them